okay so in this video we're going to go
over the history of cells we'll talk a
little bit about their discovery we'll
talk about the cell theory we'll go into
the kinds of cells such as prokaryotes
and eukaryotes we'll talk about the
diversity of cells and then we'll finish
with how we think cells may have have
become a little more complex over the
years so let's go ahead and get started
okay so the first thing I want to
mention is the history of cells and one
thing to mention is that all life is
made from cells well this is a this is a
pretty basic simplistic statement today
but there was there was a time in our
science understanding where this was not
known to us keep in mind that the cell
itself wasn't even discovered until the
1600s with the invention of the
microscope here we have a picture of the
microscope that actually discovered
cells this was a microscope that
belonged to a gentleman by the name of
Robert Hooke and Robert Hooke in 1665 he
first observed cork which happened to be
dead tree bark and now here's a picture
of what perhaps might be Robert Hooke
we're not even sure most likely that
this isn't a picture of Robert Hooke
because there have been no known
pictures of him that have survived this
happened to be a picture that was on the
Wikipedia page and so I borrowed it but
here we have a picture of some cork of
that which is again basically tree bark
cork is the bark of a type of oak tree
so pretend he sliced a real thin layer
and then put it underneath that
microscope from a moment ago let's zoom
on in and see what he saw when we zoom
on in here's an action here's the actual
drawing that Robert Hooke made back in
1665 I think I'm kind of blown away that
this is a hand-drawn image right here he
was a very artistic you can see and
notice that the the cells that he drew
all appear to be empty oh this is
because cork cells are dead all he was
looking at is the outer cell wall of the
plant cells all the inner parts have
have long since decayed and decompose
in Warren away so he really wasn't
looking at anything living in fact when
Robert Hooke first observed quark he had
no idea that cells were alive but he saw
these little boxes and he kind of you
know an analogy here he said you know
these things kind of reminded him of
tiny rooms and another name for a tiny
room would be a cell and so the name has
kind of stuck
so as time goes by we learn more and
more and more about cells and we've now
have one of the cornerstones of modern
biology which is the cell theory and so
there's three basic parts to the cell
theory but before we get into the three
parts here we have a picture of a
gentleman by the name of matthias
schleiden the german botanist the
botanist is a person who studies plants
and so he was studying plant after plant
looking at the structure of plants and
he noticed that all plant structures
were composed of cells and then here's
another German scientist a German
physiologist by the name of Theodor
Schwann and chuan and schleiden were
actually buddies and they hung out and
they went to dinner together and they
discussed their observations and based
on their discussions slidin she lightens
discussion about plants Schwann this guy
in the picture Theodor Schwann he was
working on Sal studying animal cells and
he made a similar analogy that not just
plants are based on cells but so are
animals and so he took this a step even
further and concluded that all life
plant and animal is composed of cells
and that really is part one to our cell
theory all organisms are made of cells
part two of the cell theory is that the
cell the cell is the most basic unit of
life now here we have a picture of a
cell and you can see there's a few parts
labeled lysosomes nucleus mitochondria
Golgi body rough smooth ER so my
question is if cells clearly have
smaller parts of them so why is the cell
called the basic unit of life and not
the smaller parts well the answer is
actually
pretty straightforward even though cells
have smaller parts like a mitochondria
like a rough ER those smaller parts
cannot function and cannot operate on
their own a Golgi body removed from a
cell ceases to function a lysosome
removed from a cell ceases to function
and so the basic unit of life that can
still carry on and survive and function
on its own is the cell and then here
comes a third gentleman to kind of
finish off the South Erie and this is a
another German doctor by the name of
Rudolf Virchow and he was he was a
doctor and he was working with sick
people and he was examining their cells
underneath the microscope and he noticed
that cells multiply and come from other
cells and this really is the final part
the cell theory is that cells don't just
poof out a poof out of nowhere and there
was a time when when cells we actually
thought that cells could just
spontaneously generate where we thought
life could just poof into existence and
so that this cell theory is really our
modern the beginnings kind of are of
modern cell theory or modern cell
biology here now when you combine the
work of schleiden chuan and Virgil we
again have these what's called the cell
theory but there really is a big problem
with this theory and I hope you can
identify that as part number three cells
come from other cells well if that's
true those who argue against the cell
theory and there are still some who do
argue against the cell theory what one
of the arguments they make is we're two
the first ever cell come from and a
legitimate legitimate question that
science right now really just doesn't
have a good understanding we science
does not have a good understanding for
how life could have begun how cells
could have begun so that really is one
of the big dilemmas in the big mysteries
of cell bap ok so next I'd like to go
into the diversity of cells and one
thing I want want you guys to know is
that the shape of a cell really
pens upon its function you know you can
flip through any biology textbook and
you kind of see pictures like this plant
cells animal cells are pretty much
universally depicted as the same in
textbooks plants are depicted as kind of
a rectangular or square shape cell and
animals are kind of depicted as a round
circular shaped cell and keep in mind
that when you see diagrams like this in
your textbook these are very just
simplistic general statements not every
animal cells round not every plant cell
is rectangular so what we're going to do
is go into some of the diversity of
cells so here's a great example of how
not all animal cells are round here's a
nerve cell you can see it's not round it
has these branches coming out in various
directions it's the body of a nerve
cells very stringy and elongated and
this helps do its function the function
of a nerve cell is to send electrical
messages to and from the brain that's
what you see in the animation that
yellow object is supposed to be symbolic
of an electrical message traveling to
and from the brain well when you think
of what is the advantage of nerve cells
having this shape to them well the
advantage is pretty simple those signals
those messages that go to and from the
brain they can travel a variety of
directions that's good because what if a
person is not-- what if somebody has
some nerve damage
what if some of those branches have been
damaged due to some kind of accident
well if some branches are damaged but
other branches remain intact there's a
good chance the person can still send
messages to and from the brain and they
won't have very very you know severe
disabilities but if all of their
branches are damaged and they are not
able to send any messages to and from
the brain that person very well could
suffer from some sort of paralysis you
know good analogy for a nerve cell is
when we look at a map of the United
States pretend that you wanted to drive
from City a to city B and my question
says could you get from City a to city B
if interstate 80 was suddenly closed
interstate 80 is the red line
between city a and city B could you get
to city B if interstate 80 were closed
the answer should be obvious absolutely
yes you just have to go a different
direction you may have to use one of
those blue routes to get to city B so
you may have to go out of your way a
little bit but eventually you could
still get the city B just go a different
direction the same works with nerve
cells if your nerve cells have damage to
them if some of the branches of a nerve
cell have damaged there's a good chance
the message can still get to and from
the brain just by traveling different
directions around other branches another
type of cell I want to mention our red
blood cells and you can see that they're
round and disc like in shape well this
really helps them do their function
their function is to carry oxygen
throughout the blood you know there's a
reason we put round tires on automobiles
round tires help an automobile roll and
use less energy as the as you drive down
the road well here's a vein with our B
C's traveling through them RBC's Dan
stands for red blood cells and you know
there are parts of the body where the
veins and arteries are so narrow that
red blood cells have to travel through
them single-file they're that thin and
so clearly having round red blood cells
allows them to roll hopefully not get
stuck in those narrow veins and arteries
and the last example on this one on the
slide here are skin cells their shape is
very broad and very flat
well that really helps them perform
their function you might know the
function of skin cells is to cover and
protect the body
so having cells that are broad and flat
allows them to cover more area not only
are skin cells broad and flat to cover
more area but the skin cells actually
overlap one another you probably know
that skin cells come in various layers
and so by having cells a skin cell
overlap and overlap and overlap another
skin cell it adds more and more layers
of protection
great analogy is for instance like this
roof here here's a picture of a roof and
these are shingles on a roof your skin
cells act like shingles on a roof so
when it rains you know the water just
simply rolls down the shingles and onto
the ground and more importantly it stays
dry on the inside so having skin cells
arranged like shingles really does help
keep out unwanted materials your skin is
really the first line of defense your
skin keeps out viruses keeps out
bacteria and so your skin is really your
first line of defense in your immune
system okay the next thing I want to
mention are two broad categories of
cells in the picture we have a category
of cells known as a prokaryote and these
are cells that do not possess a nucleus
and other membrane-bound organelles you
know in middle school perhaps you had to
build a shoebox diagram a shoebox model
of a cell and in building that model
perhaps you labeled things mitochondria
and the rough ER and the Golgi body you
might be wondering where are those
things in this picture prokaryotes do
not have those the parts I just
mentioned a nucleus a mitochondria a
chloroplast a rough ER a Golgi body
these are all membrane bound prokaryotes
don't have them so these are the
simplest cells on earth not only are
they the simplest cells on earth but we
also think they're the oldest they're
the first cells the first life to ever
inhabit planet Earth and reason we think
this number one is they're the simplest
in structure but number two when we look
at the fossil record you know we find
evidence of prokaryotic life about 3.5
3.6 billion years ago and so that really
does predate the earliest other kind of
cells which we'll mention in just a
moment prokaryotes have a more common
name to them you may have simply heard
them called bacteria so
bacteria are prokaryotes and prokaryotes
are bacteria if I were at to ask you do
bacteria have a nucleus you could say no
they don't because bacteria are
prokaryotes and they don't have a
nucleus or other membrane-bound
organelles ok the second category of
cells besides of prokaryote is a
eukaryote and these are really just the
opposite these are cells that do possess
a nucleus and membrane-bound organelles
so these cells are much more complex
when you look at the diagram you see a
lot of the parts that you perhaps
labeled when you maybe made a shoebox
model in middle school you know you can
see the nucleus because it's membrane
bound you can see a mitochondria it too
has an outer membrane to it you can see
the Golgi apparatus it has an outer
membrane to it so eukaryotic cells are
much more complex not only are they more
complex but we think they evolved from
para prokaryotes we think that bacteria
prokaryotic bacteria were the first
inhabitants of Earth and later on
eukaryotes evolved from them we find
evidence of eukaryotes around 2 billion
years ago and that very much is after
prokaryotes prokaryotes appear to come
first in eukaryotes appear to come
second so we'll go into how we think
prokaryotes eventually led to the
evolution of eukaryotes in just a moment
but here's a quick list of examples of
cells that are eukaryotic here is an
amoeba which is a type of protists that
if you're not familiar with Protista
they're organisms that microscopic one
cell in size the kind of living pond
water I'm sure you're familiar with
mushrooms mushrooms are a type of fungus
I'm sure you're familiar with trees
trees are a type of plant and I'm sure
you're familiar with frogs frogs are a
type of animal humans humans are also a
type of animal and so humans very much
our cells are eukaryotic okay so here's
the final topic is the evolution of
eukaryotes well the evolution of
eukaryotes can really be summed up with
a theory
recalled the endosymbiosis theory now
this theory tries to explain how the
mitochondria and the chloroplasts became
a part of the cell while at one time
kind of a neat little theory here at one
time we're pretty certain that the
chloroplasts in the mitochondria were
both free living organisms in the
picture I just have a chloroplast
ancestor in the picture I didn't draw
the mitochondria in this picture just
for simplicity and I didn't want to have
too much clutter once we go through this
animation well so if science believes
that the mitochondria and chloroplasts
were once free living organisms and this
is called a theory there has to be
evidence to support that theory and the
evidence is actually pretty overwhelming
the mitochondria and the chloroplasts
each contain their own DNA that right
there is some of the best evidence that
the mitochondria and chloroplasts used
to be an organism all by themselves it's
also interesting to note that the
mitochondria and chloroplasts can
replicate and multiply they have their
own ribosomes they make their own
proteins so they do a lot of cellular
functions even though they today the
chloroplasts and mitochondria are not
cells they are parts of cells it's kind
of interesting they're almost like a
cell trapped inside of a bigger cell
well how did this happen what's the
process for how this took place well in
the animation we're about to go through
here we have a large orange cell and
it's engulfing the green chloroplast
ancestor well now this large orange cell
has an advantage and this is where we
get into the endosymbiosis theory if you
can if you if you can trap for instance
that green chloroplast ancestor that
orange larger cell now has an advantage
chloroplasts you may know do
photosynthesis and they make sugar if
you can have a part designed to make
food for yourself you now have an
advantage over your competitors and so
each the green chloroplast and the
orange larger cell continue to multiply
so in my animation the
green chloroplasts are multiplying and
becoming more plentiful but they're all
trapped inside of this large and
yourself
well that large orange cell is going to
grow and divide and break into two and
multiply as well so now we have two
cells that have an advantage of making
sugar by having these chloroplast parts
inside of them and this process simply
continues over and over and over again
and over time each has become completely
dependent on one another the
chloroplasts and mitochondria are
dependent on the orange cell for
protection and yet the orange cell is
completely dependent on the mitochondria
because it helps make energy and
dependent on the green chloroplasts
because it helps make food and so this
is really some a summary of the
endosymbiosis theory and how we think
eukaryotic cells became in to exist and
so as we wrap up this video go ahead and
pause the video if you're in my biology
class pause the video and try to answer
these 9 questions here put them on a
separate sheet of paper I'd be happy to
check your answers for accuracy either
before school or after school one day
good luck